extent nearly 150 years after abolishing
slavery the Netherlands has apologized
for its role in the slave trade
from the 17th to the 19th century Dutch
colonizers kidnapped an estimated 600
000 African men women and children and
shipped them to South America enslaving
them on plantations
they were not alone several European
Empires traded in millions of human
lives
from the Netherlands today I apologize
on behalf of the Dutch government for
the actions of the Dutch state in the
past posthumously to all enslaved people
who have suffered from that act
worldwide to their daughters and sons
and to all their descendants
the apology comes months after the
recommendation of an advisory panel set
up by the government after worldwide
protests against the murder of American
George Floyd in 2020.
it described the slave trade as crimes
against humanity with ongoing impact for
Descendants
the Netherlands formally abolished
slavery in 1863 but the practice lasted
another decade in its territories
including Suriname today sixty percent
of the population of the tiny Caribbean
country lives below the poverty line
groups from former colonies have
criticized the timing of the apology
calling it hurried and haphazard with a
lack of consultation
rights campaigners say more needs to be
done to address racism in Dutch Society
they point to the practice of blackface
during the festive season where people
dress up as the Christmas tale
characters warty P which translates as
black pea
prime minister Rota says more than 200
million dollars will be allocated to
awareness campaigns and 29 million to
opening a slavery museum for many
descendants of slaves it's just not
enough
Human Rights Watch says a true Reckoning
requires reparations including
restitution compensation and
Rehabilitation
but for now the Dutch government isn't
willing to go that far
IA Carr Al Jazeera